[Applause]
yeah I'm so sorry
so yeah so I was safe to her surprise at
the end so now let's talk about my um
Python app icon Namibia experience and
why is this different from the others
so who knows where is Namibia yes it's a
it's in Africa is in the south part of
Africa is very near to South Africa so
yeah so it's a very um less populated
country let's put it that way is 80% of
it is that's it why am I going there
because there's a bike on there
can you imagine like in a desert there
are people starting to use Python and do
some amazing things by the way this is
my tweeter and I'm like github so feel
free to say hi okay so because it's
selecting time speed up so yeah why you
have to go there and why it's difference
because it's a conference in that Bri
and it's like a summer holiday can you
believe it can you go to anywhere in
Europe in fact we I feel like a summer
holiday no so you have to go to an
economy BIA and also like it's not a big
conference as I said it's like a less
that like less populated country so the
you only got like around 70 80 people
there's the conference attendee and you
know we're like 10 of us this may be
from like we're international you know
I'm conference goers or we're from
another country and a half of it it's
like students you can see there's some
high school student in the middle there
in their uniform and but they're super
smart and bright and I've talked to them
and they all have their ideas they
wanted one guy wants to have his own
startup it's amazing I was like how did
you get him here in London maybe yeah
that's how many others like so party
yeah and also the conference run in a
super chill timetable so basically at
the in the morning of the day nobody
knows what the timetable exactly will be
it is a wrong idea and then is subjected
to change which is very exciting in my
point of view because suddenly
like you know like oh it's my time to
give a talk okay I don't know so yes
it's very relaxing and you have more
time to you know have lunch outside and
chat with people that's very good
also we have a very fancy dress code so
on the right hand side is Sandrine if
you have met her but she's also like a
go to Phi Beta a lot and yeah it's just
in a traditional Namibian dress and also
I have the got to wear the hat which is
very funny and also why going all the
way to Africa because there are no codes
you can see like on the picture on the
right hand side this base that they are
the local organizers and lots of them
are actually university student and they
you know they learn Python in university
and in their organizing this conference
and then they're very nice they bring us
to a local trip that we go to a local
market and they're like people
cracking a skull of a goat Oh in opening
is like a bit scary and also they are
like worms on a market that like you can
find and cook it yourself so yeah is the
amazing experience also evening we go to
open mic so instead of giving a
lightning talk like what I'm doing now
like in evening I go to a random you
know theatre and then we are giving
poems so yeah it's very interesting and
also I have to emphasize this point they
have a really diversity in gender so you
can see in the picture half of the
attendees so for my workshop they are
they're women they have no idea like oh
like like 90% of the people going to the
conference movie male know they don't
have that idea they're like oh we are
here to learn and and there's a lot of
women they are working for big companies
you know me beer and they're very smart
they want to learn to use Python in data
analysis they want to use that at work
this is amazing
and we have to do better in London here
so we are on the newspaper also we have
like a column like introduced pipe and
vivia schools in expand ITR to expand I
T so we have featured so yeah we found
it obviously of course we drink beer and
then read what they it's good and also
wait for the sticker there if you can
see the is where I'm pointing at there's
like a sticker of my condo me yeah so is
the traffic of Capricorn because after
the conference some of us went on a trip
to drive through the passage and then we
go through the tropical tropic of
capricorn and then we put a sticker
there like everybody does so when you go
there please find the sticker okay and
we write the giant Python na in a desert
I don't think you just see it there
because you know the wind will flow the
sand in RVs but we leave a mark
everywhere which is amazing and then
unfortunately we had a flat tire after
we we go to write a Python na and um so
we have to change the tire but we do it
in a cool reveal style you can see
somebody was holding in the menu and
somebody was trying to have a look and
then you know somebody was holding at hi
and somebody was like kind of managing
like that's the project manager there
and when you as the project manager
three years a team so yeah so I I can't
show you everything so please go there
and see their website is there and I
think they were posed about next year
very soon and then um I think it'll be
around the same time it could be in
fabric could be much but around that
time when the weather's amazing sunshine
all the time not like London's around
please also if you want to go eat out
summertime because whatever gets the
kids you know I don't know why and but
if you've decided to go in August there
is the Python Africa that you could go
so yeah you can also look at the details
on their website um yeah so that's a
haiku Namibia and the surprises here
Wiki picker so recently what I did it's
like I have um I have this I contribute
to open source by the way if you don't
know we know but this time I was
challenging myself I try to make my own
library so this one is coffee can mix so
if you have part of candies in the store
it's like picking your candy and put it
like a mix and what it does it's like is
for stacking if you have let's say you
have some circular model that you want
to do some fancy stacking to increase
the accuracy for whatever reason then
you can use this because it's very easy
to use I will show you the documentation
you sage right so you just kind of you
have your model and then you just be a
layer and then you stack the layers one
on top of each other and then it will
become a stack and then for the stack is
actually do what cycle and allows you to
do it have fit and you can project so
it's this first simple but is this handy
when you need it what I want people to
contribute now of course like use it and
then you know if there's any issues let
me know anyway I can improve it let me
know you can you know give me an issue
here and yeah and and right now I am
trying to do this let me show you here
right trying to do this I will post it
laters right um I'm trying to have this
local competition because I'm going to
Europe - which is which got to be the
conference before hi Daisy London so you
got to do you can do both in a week yes
so yeah um yeah and I need a bit of a
logo so I can like get some sticker
printed and I can give it away so please
if you think that your artist please
help me out and design a logo if your
logo depicts you will have some stickers
and then you'll be credit so thank you
so much
[Applause]